Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie.This will be my Ahsoka Episode 5 video
There are a whole bunch of Star Wars
Easter Eggs and references,
so we'll break it all down.
I know you have tons of questions
about what was going on
with the Anakin Skywalker.
Was he a force ghost?
Is he a dis god now? Don't worry.
We'll explain all that.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
We're doing a giveaway for Disney
plus memberships.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and just post your favorite moments
from the episode on the video.
So care for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet.
We'll just start at the beginning, work
our way through, shot by shot.
Talking about Easter Eggs,
wtf moments, what's really going
on with Anakin Skywalker?
interesting, interesting, interesting.
Starting with the title Shadow Warrior,
which is a super deep cut reference
to a samurai film
by Akira Kurosawa called Kagemusha.
The name literally translates
to Shadow Warrior.
George Lucas was also credited as one of
the executive producers on that movie.
most of Akira Kurosawa's
other samurai films are all amazing,
but they heavily influenced George Lucas
when he was making the original trilogy.
hard to really appreciate
the true genius of Kurosawa, I think,
until you've seen a few of the films
and then you've been able
to see other films at the same time
and be able to realize his visual style.
My my favorite of all time is really Seven
Samurai,
The original movie was about a thief
who was hired to impersonate
a dying warlord, and when he dies,
the thief just continues in the role,
but eventually is tested
when he's forced to lead a bunch of troops
into battle with the thought
that he might get a ton of people killed.
so in the context of this episode,
Ahsoka is the shadow warrior and Aniket
is the dying warlord, dying Jedi
she is replacing
and he's testing her commitment
and her getting used to the idea
that she'll be leading people into battle
who might wind up getting killed likes
to being read her new Padawan.
just in general, the entire Ahsoka series
is meant to feel like a very samurai
film type of vibe.
Kind of like her episode
of The Mandalorian Season two.
That's why a lot of the soundtrack
of the Ahsoka series
sounds kind of like the Star Wars
version of a Samurai film.
one of his big lessons to Ahsoka
is that she is his legacy.
She's a shadow warrior, just like him.
meaning that there is this
twinge of darkness within them,
but they themselves are good people.
Like there's more to them
than just being this darkness.
of couple funny moments
about that during the episode
where he was basically telling her like,
okay,
I get you're probably pissed off
about all the Darth Vader stuff,
but there's more to me
than just the Darth Vader of it all.
the actual
opening scene starts with Hera Jacen
in Chopper down on the hinge
in the waypoint investigating
what happened
during a soldier's battle with Balan skull
and what happened to Sabine.
They zoom in and hands on the broken
pieces.
The map, which has made foreshadow
how it was.
So can the others will get to the other
galaxy and how she uses her abilities
in the force to sense what happened
after she fell off the cliff.
very convenient.
Sort of like a Jedi instant replayability.
one of my theories is they would use
the space whales to get the other galaxy.
But I wasn't quite sure
how they were going to accomplish it.
They basically went full Pinocchio fool.
Jonah
If you want to make Bible references,
literally fly into the mouth of the whale
and it will just carry you there.
Kind of like Han Solo in the Millennium
Falcon flying into the space.
Slug they bind who?
Yang Who discovered what happened earlier,
holding Sabine's Mandalorian helmet.
Jacen, who is strong in the force.
If it wasn't clear, they kind of implied
that during Star Wars Rebels sends
is what's happening to Ahsoka, though
even though he doesn't totally understand
exactly what's happening.
that's why you can see him pause
and look out beyond the cliff like you
kind of get what's going on.
It's like, Oh,
he realizes kind of that she's there,
but she's not there at the same time.
Then we finally go back to Ahsoka and again
Skywalker's reunion in the world
between Worlds.
In the exact moment
after episode four ended
and again gets in a couple of good jokes
about her getting really old
and him
looking at the exact same that he did
during the Clone Wars in her
losing her fight with Baylor in school,
losing or like,
Oh yeah, you definitely lost big time.
The important thing here, though,
is that he knows
everything that happened to Ahsoka
and he knows what's going on
with balance school,
which kind of clarifies
exactly how he exists here.
Like, what's going on? Is he a force
ghost? Is he immortals God?
Is it the real? And it came from the Clone
Wars.
What's going on
so many questions about this.
You could do like ten different videos
just explaining how this works.
What I think is actually going on here
is that because this and again,
has knowledge of everything that happens
when he becomes Darth Vader
and after he died,
this is meant to be a present day.
And again, Skywalker, who's already been
through all those events, he already died.
But he's not exactly a force ghost.
So I think he's closer
to being like the mortis gods.
But he hasn't, like, completely replaced
the Mortes gods or anything like that.
I am sure Dave Filoni is going to get tons
and tons of questions about this
every time he goes to a convention.
From now to the end of time
But if he were just a regular force ghost,
he would have that same kind of blue
outline that all the force
ghost that you see in the Star Wars
movies had,
they would have made him look like that
if it was just a simple force ghost,
which he is not.
That's why I think that he's something
a little bit more powerful than the Force
Ghost themselves.
there are a lot of people that thought
that he replaced one of the more less gods
like maybe he became the son
or the daughter
or the father
replaced one of them, basically.
But that's not exactly what happened.
Like Ahsoka didn't replace the daughter
or anything like that,
he basically explains that Ahsoka can still
return to the world of the living.
And when he says that's
because she remembers
what happened to her in that's good
that she remembers.
It's a reference to the way the Force
Ghosts work in the Star Wars universe.
Basically he's saying that she died
and she can't go back to the world
of the living
so the kind of referencing
just the way that dying works
in the Star Wars universe,
the way that force ghosts work,
pretty much
everyone, every living
being in the Star Wars universe, even
very powerful Jedi masters like Yoda,
people like Anakin Skywalker down
to normal people
like just regular old people.
when they die, their essence
just becomes one with the force.
The difference is that Jedi,
who are trained in how to become force
goes, can retain their consciousness
after they die like their sense of self.
Those are what force
ghosts are basically the essence of people
who used to be alive
but just retain their consciousness.
the other thing too is that force
goes can also influence the world
of the living too.
Like force Ghost Yoda is able to hold down
the lightning strike.
so and again is basically telling Ahsoka
that even though she kind of died,
she retained the knowledge
of who she is, her consciousness.
There's still a chance
that she can return back to her body
in the war, that the living
this is actually pretty close to the way
they explain resurrection
in the Marvel Moon Knight series,
in order to resurrect
the rules that your body has to be whole,
or you can transplant your consciousness
into another body
if it's a dead body or the person's will
that you're replacing.
Is this weaker than your own will
but and again claims that Ahsoka has come
to the world between worlds
to see him with the purpose
of finishing her training.
so that answers the question of how Ahsoka
was pulled into the war between worlds,
and Akin is the one that did that.
I didn't see any owls flying around
or hooting anywhere.
You can let me know if you saw any.
So I don't think there's any references
to Mirai.
Usually when Ahsoka shows up in scenes,
Mariah's somewhere in the background.
during Star Wars
rebels, when Ezra was able to enter
the world between worlds, it was implied
that the mortis gods
were the reason why he was able to enter.
They helped him enter.
So that's why I think a lot of people
are thinking that this version of
and again
after he died, sort of ascended to a more
this God kind of like position guarding
the world between worlds which is possible
that would also explain
why he's not showing up as a force ghost
in all the events of the sequel movies
like he's too busy
guarding the World Between Worlds
to just show up
and talk to everybody
in the worlds of the living all the time.
Ryan Johnson said that
he briefly considered having force goes
and it can show up during The Last Jedi,
but because Luke Skywalker
had such a bigger relationship with Yoda
during the previous Star Wars movies,
they wanted it to be Yoda instead.
But also because whole arc in this episode
is a very Gandalf Lord of the Rings
kind of arc.
It's a huge, deep
cut Easter egg for something
Dave Filoni also said a long time ago.
she's going basically from being Gandalf
the gray, like Ahsoka the gray
to Gandalf the white silk the white,
which is why she goes from gray robes
in the episode to white robes.
Later, at the end of the episode,
Star Wars Rebels fans will also remember
that she was wearing the white robes
at the end of the animated series.
And even though they did that scene
in live action with her
wearing different colored clothing,
I think Dave Filoni has idea
when he did that animated episode, is it
Ahsoka
had already been through this experience
and become a soldier, the white,
so to speak, some of you might remember
this, Dave Filoni made a drawing comparing
Ahsoka to Gandalf back
when Rise of Skywalker came out
answering this fan
question of whether or not she was alive
during the events of the sequel trilogy.
Because there was that scene
where all the voices of the Jedi
were calling out to Rey
when she was fighting Emperor Palpatine.
So people are like,
Wait a minute, these are all dead Jedi.
Does that mean that Ahsoka is dead too?
Dave Filoni only answer to
this was just a post, this picture,
and it was a joke
where Gandalf was talking to Ahsoka
saying people thought that I was dead too,
implying that Ahsoka was still alive
during the events of the sequels.
but I think he was making the Gandalf joke
because, yes,
the idea is that she did kind of die,
but then came back to life
just like Gandalf
did in the Lord of the Rings movies.
during the events of the episode,
we're just actually seeing that happen
You notice when he activates his light
saber,
it is manikins, light saber,
not Darth Vader's.
A lot of people were confused about this
because when we saw him at the end of
episode four, the lighting was so dark
it was kind of hard to make things out.
he makes a Darth Vader reference, though,
saying he's heard someone say,
I won't fight you anymore.
That was what Luke Skywalker told him
during Return of the Jedi.
So this confirms that this version of
and again,
isn't necessarily a force ghost,
but he might be kind of like a mortis God.
Or so after he died.
Like he remembers everything that happened
during the original trilogy
and after his death.
this also helps them avoid the problem of
what would Anna can do
if he was pulled from the past
with all this for knowledge
of what would happen in the future
and becoming Darth Vader.
So this is a version of and again
from much later in his own timeline.
This also explains why he can appear in
any form that he wants to.
He can look younger and he can use
multiple different kinds of lightsabers,
like he uses his original lightsaber,
But then during their last fight,
he switches to the red blade back on
cetus at the hinge when Heron, who Yang
are still trying to figure out
what happened.
You notice in the background,
like zooming in, hands out,
Jacen is just staring out
over the cliff with chopper.
That's because he's continuing to sense
the smoke in the world between worlds.
Takes a little while,
but eventually he convinces Hera.
Oh, no, no.
I feel her out there
and she starts to listen to it to
Jacen starts getting a little more
detailed on what it is that he's sensing.
He actually hears an account in the show
because lightsaber
fights out over the waves
here starts to hear it too.
And the reason why she can do that
is because of the whole Sabine Wren
explainer
for how the force is supposed to work.
Now the whole idea is that
everybody has the force,
everyone in the universe has the force,
but only some people are deeply connected
to it.
so people like Hera and Sabine
who don't have a strong connection
to the force
naturally or like natural ability
the way that Jacen and Ahsoka
have had to try way harder.
But eventually like
if someone listened hard enough,
they could also sense those lightsabers
clashing over the waves to
but obviously all of these Jacen scenes
and even later in the episode
two or two tease that they're eventually
going to train him in the force
like maybe Ezra will do it at some point.
But that's probably why Julianne kept
telling him that he wouldn't do it
because someone else will do it
and it won't be Ahsoka.
So Ezra would be like
the next best person.
cars.
And D.va also makes
a big princess Leia reference, claiming
Leia is covering for them while
their squad of X-Wings went rogue at sea,
tossed against the will of the Senate.
Leia during this time
period would look kind of like this.
this would be after
she left Luke Skywalker's training
to give birth to Ben Solo, Kylo Ren.
But before she took him to Luke
Skywalker's Jedi Academy to be trained.
a lot of people asking
what happened with Leia
during the events of The Mandalorian
during this part of the timeline,
We saw Luke Skywalker a couple of times,
make sense that they'd eventually start
referencing Leia at some point.
Right
now, during the events of this series,
she's really active in The New Republic.
We get a very short but really cool
badass lightsaber fight between us.
So again and again,
you notice that his technique is just like
it was during the events of the prequels,
but because Ahsoka's skill
has gotten so much better,
she's gotten older.
She's
actually able to get a hint in on him
then because he's so much more powerful
now in the form of the SS, he's
able to smash the walkway
in the world between worlds.
Sending her into this other past
history of hers was kind of
like a combination of the past, but
also he's manipulating it a little bit.
a lot of people are also going
to have questions about this, too,
like because this is the World
Between Worlds is connected to all points
in time, in space.
Like everything everywhere, all at once
to make another joke.
does this mean that she actually traveled
literally into the past,
or is it more like a force vision?
my assumption right
now, just based on what they showed us,
is this kind of a combination of the two
things like Anna can in his current
form is able to change things
like you would in a force vision.
But he's also drawing
upon real things that happened in the past
because of the way
the world between worlds works.
But this is why when she wakes
up, she's a child.
There are all these clone troopers
around them.
They're male. The Clone Wars.
she's only got her one green light saber.
I couldn't find out
who's playing the younger version of.
So I didn't see her name in the credits.
So if you did spot it,
just write it below in the comments.
and again.
Looks exactly like he did
during the Clone Wars though
the exact same armor
a silk is wearing her padawan braid.
when she says
this is one of their first missions,
she's talking about
the events of the Clone Wars
movie, which was the very beginning
of the Clone Wars series.
this was the first mission
that they went on together
after she had been assigned
to become in against Padawan.
She runs through the smoke in the shadows.
The battle has ended
and there are tons of casualties.
The whole idea is that during this battle,
during the Clone Wars,
it was meant to be Anakins
for solo command experience.
In the time the Clone Troopers died
like a bunch of people.
But you have to remember that
this is Sokka is the older Ahsoka
just in the younger ahsoka's body.
So she's grown way
closer to the clones over that period.
So that's why she's mourning them
so much harder during the scene.
the lesson
that the younger version of Anakin
is trying to teach a soldier
during this event
is that there's always a price to be paid.
You're always going to wind up
having people who follow you die.
And even though that sucks, it
is something that you need to deal with.
The whole idea in present day
is that a Sophia's
big problem is that she keeps trying
to avoid getting close to people,
pushing them away,
hoping that she won't get them killed too,
and that's why she left Sabine
before her train was complete.
Before the events of the series
pick up Sabine incorrectly thinks
that Ahsoka left her because she hated her
and didn't want to be her master.
But really, Ahsoka
didn't want to get to being killed.
so the younger Aniket
is trying to remind younger Ahsoka,
even though it's older Ahsoka,
that she's not supposed to be perfect.
She's going to make mistakes,
people are going to die, but that's okay.
In order to live
she's going to have to fight.
She can't quit this battle
because of what's happening
with Thrawn in present day.
so manikin is using her
first battle is a metaphor
for what's going to be happening
with this upcoming war,
this upcoming star war
that she'll be fighting against.
Thrawn
we go back to the world
of the living with here
and everyone else
looking for Ahsoka off the coast.
And while she's talking about chasing
ghosts, they have a picture of
live action Keynan Duras on her dashboard
way more prominently this time to
this is meant to be Freddie Prinze
Jr who filmed a new scene for this
picture here
because he claimed before that
he was never going to do a live action
Kanon cameos scene,
but turns out he already kind of did
The special reference here just feels like
Dave Filoni teasing us that we might get
an actual Kanan scene at some point.
I don't know, maybe a flashback or a force
ghost somehow.
Them invoking live action.
Kanan there's also a bit of a funny moment
with Hu Yang trying to explain
Anakin Skywalker to Hera, like, oh,
he was intense.
That was his way of kind of explain
the Darth Vader of it
all. Like, Oh yeah, he got really,
really intense during this scene.
They also have a couple of funny moments
with Chopper
and he's gone like this
through the entire episode.
Any time you hear Chopper talking
on the comms, it always sounds like he's
swearing up a storm, just making
fun of people like cursing like a sailor
there have been a lot of jokes about R2-D2
doing the same thing in the past.
Like what is really beeping.
There is just a bunch of curse words
Speaking of Anakin Skywalker, though,
there's like a hilarious deleted scene
from Revenge of the Sith, where
Anthony and Skywalker
speaks in R2-D2 Droid language
like he makes a bunch of beeps.
Trying to speak like R2 is ridiculous.
It's broken.
Can you understand what he's saying?
I'm not a protocol droid.
I'm pretty sure that beep is down.
I sense Count Dooku is above us.
Oh, yes, yes, yes, you're right.
Beep is up.
I think.
that wasn't him being funny either.
That was like a real scene that
George Lucas had him film for the movie.
Seriously?
Like it wasn't meant to be tongue in cheek
know, you understand why they cut that
during the final edit
the next period that Ahsoka winds up
traveling to is during the end
of the Clone Wars season
seven during the final siege of Mandalore.
So if you watched the final Clone Wars
episodes,
this is basically the live action
version of that
she led her own squad of clone troopers
against Darth Maul and his Maul Delorean's
That's why the clone Troopers
helmets are painted
orange to pay homage to her orange skin.
And you see the mold warriors
with their horns on the helmets.
this took place long
before the events of Star Wars rebels.
But Bo-Katan also fought with her here.
They know each other well.
If you remember,
during the Mandalorian season two,
She's the person who told Mando
where to find a soldier.
we get a very quick voiceover cameo
from Tamura Morison, who's playing Rex.
a lot of people also wondering
if we'll see a Rex cameo during.
So I'm assuming
this is probably going to be it,
but maybe if they do a season two,
we'll see a live action Rex in present day
like an older version of Rex,
when the older present day Anakin says
he doesn't know this battle.
It's because this was happening
during the events of Revenge
of the Sith in Anarchy
was back on Coruscant with Obi-Wan Kenobi,
like it was happening as the beginning
of Revenge of the Sith, but taking place
The last time Aniket and Ahsoka
actually met before their big reunion
by during Star Wars Rebels Wait later
when he becomes Darth Vader was right
before Ahsoka left to go on this
particular mission when she was returning
through hyperspace to course
that's when order 66 actually went down.
So it kind of gives you an idea
for the timeline
of when all this stuff was happening
then Anna can basically tells Ahsoka
that he'll be with her forever,
metaphorically and literally,
because, you know,
he can also become a force ghost,
but his teachings will live on in her.
She's his legacy.
One of his legacy is at least like he has
a legacy of death and destruction
because he was Darth Vader.
and basically Ahsoka has to carry all that
with her and she'll pass on some of that
to Sabine, her student, in the same way
that she was an Indian student.
But she doesn't have to be trapped
by all the bad history
that comes with that,
like the legacy of Darth Vader.
Like it doesn't have to be
all about the death and destruction
This time he confronts her again.
But notice that his eyes have changed to
Sith yellow like they were
at the end of Revenge of the Sith.
He still has his original lightsaber
from Revenge of the Sith,
but the Kyber crystal is bleeding red now,
this is a bit of a change.
Like obviously this is just and again,
messing with the soldier,
trying to teach her this lesson.
His red lightsaber
actually was something that he built long
after the events of Revenge of the Sith
because Obi-Wan Kenobi
took his blue lightsaber
and eventually gave it to Luke Skywalker.
really cool transition here
when he kicks her out of the past
into the present of the world
between worlds.
You can hear Darth Vader's breathing
sounds as he walks through the smoke
in his red light saber as it flashes
between images of Darth Vader in.
And it can again,
that's where the title comes from.
The Shadow Warrior.
Basically,
she's able to defeat him, spares his life.
But that was kind of what he was looking
for, Like
he was hoping that she would do that
and choose life.
remember,
this is an and trying to test her
Basically it's her having her
call to action, so to speak.
Like this is her inner most cave scene
kind of like Luke's cave scene
on Dagobah only hers is happening
in the world between worlds.
She comes out of it with renewed resolve
in her fight against Thrawn
like she won't give up in her quest
to stop Thrawn Indians eyes in his face
turn back to normal.
He congratulate her
and then disappears into nothingness.
So in all people would be like,
what happened to him? Where did he go?
like I said, I don't think he's meant to
be a force ghost in the traditional sense.
I think he's something
a little bit more powerful than that.
So essentially he can do anything
he wants to in the world between worlds.
But he operates a little bit like a
mortis, God force ghost kind of situation.
So even though visibly he's disappeared,
technically he's still all over the place
all around watching Ahsoka.
but I also think that he is
the person who pushed her back
into the world of the living,
and he's the person that pulled her
into the world between worlds, like,
I think, and again, was behind all of this
like I said, Dave Filoni
will probably clarify this at some point.
Maybe he won't.
Like, maybe he'll just mess with people
for the rest of time.
either way.
And Akin seems like he's a little bit
more powerful than Force Ghost Yoda
or Quick on giant Obi-Wan Kenobi.
Basically, like all the Force ghost
that we've seen before,
probably because of his connection
to the force, like he was literally
a child of the force, the Chosen one, Her
consciousness travels back into her body.
They pull it out of the ocean.
She changes into her Gandalf
the white robes, like I said,
turning from Gandalf
the gray into Gandalf the white Ahsoka.
The gray turns into Ahsoka, the white.
notice again that Jacen also senses her
in the force when they get closer.
That's why he knows that they found her
and she's still alive
before he actually sees her body.
the other interesting thing here, too,
is when we see her in her bed here,
she doesn't have her headdress on.
I think this is the first time
we've seen Rosario Dawson's live action.
Ahsoka, without anything on her head,
she then helps them figure out
what really happened to Sabine
by using her Jedi ability to sense what
happened in the past around this area.
Instant replay.
Like I said,
they make a couple more references
about Jacen
being really strong in the force
and who Yang
makes a couple more references
about the Clone Wars.
Like that's
what he means when he says, I'm
not going to train
you like it's going to be Ezra.
That's why they're training him. But also
he knows how to build a lightsaber
because that's literally his function.
he was created to help Jedi build their
lightsaber since the Old Republic era.
So he knows
every known Jedi is lightsaber design
going back many thousands of years.
there are a couple references to that
in earlier episodes where he was
searching through his databanks to find
Senate and balance schools lightsaber.
But the reason why he couldn't find Austin
Heights is because it was built
after the fall of the Jedi Order
so he wouldn't have it in his databanks.
The New Republic shows up to basically
arrest everyone because
they suck, apparently in present day here
is basically going to lose her command.
But because we know Thrawn is coming back,
even if she does lose her
command, eventually,
they'll probably give it back to her like,
Oh, you know what?
You were probably right about Thrawn
coming back with that giant space fleet.
in Ahsoka basically uses the space wheels,
the pergolas to help
take her to the other galaxy.
I love that theories about this, but not
exactly sure how it is going to play out.
the scene of her communicating with them
is a lot like the Star Wars
rebels episodes when they flew with them.
But this part is much bigger than before.
She speaks with one of the larger ones
just because it would be
one of the leaders of their pod,
you know, kind of like the Dragons
on Game of Thrones.
The older they get, the bigger
they get, Carson TV keeps the New Republic
at bay to prevent the pearls
from getting spooked and taking off.
And then Jacen references
the events of the Star Wars
rebels ending in how they use them
to get rid of Thrawn.
the whole idea is that Ezra befriended
the poor girls earlier on the series
and they did him
a solid by basically taking Thrawn seventh
Fleet to the other galaxy.
Ezra just happened to be on board
one of Thrones ships when that happened.
give the joke here too
is that he slips in a far, far away?
Reference to the joke we make is
they were taken to a galaxy far, far away.
Like all the Star Wars opening
title crawls.
in basically, Ahsoka talks to the poor girl
through the force
and goes for Pinocchio, riding inside
its belly to the other galaxy.
they made the effect of them
traveling into hyperspace the same
it was during the animated series.
the only other thing of note here
during this ending scene
is that Captain Gerard, here
with The New Republic
is like a brand new character.
There were some giraffes
during the old Republic game,
but I don't know if that's
meant to be canon
to the actual live action Star Wars stuff.
most in episode six next week.
Early prediction will probably be them
in the other galaxy.
We might get our first look at Thrawn,
maybe Ezra Bridger
But I think the last two episodes,
like episodes seven and eight,
will all be that other galaxy
with them figuring out how to come back
and then actually coming back.
still a ton of questions
like what else is going on with
the other important people in the galaxy?
What are they going to do
when Thrawn comes back in?
What's the deal
with this other galaxy like?
What does it actually look like
in this other galaxy?
overall, it was a pretty solid episode.
But there are a ton of Easter Eggs
and references
if you spotted any during the episode
that I didn't talk about during the video,
just write them
below in the comments in my Episode 6
trailer video we'll post tomorrow,
so be sure to enable orders for my channel
so you don't miss that.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up
to click here for that video edit the link
as soon as I post it and click here
for all my other Star Wars Ahsoka episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!